let's go uh oh you know who we haven't
heard from for for a while our friend
tamisha in new york city tamisha welcome
thank you how is everything everything's
good
um
um i'm calling because i wanted to just
quickly talk about the absurdity of the
guns talk yeah from right where they say
oh um let's arm doors locked doors and
rooftops but
that whole premise doesn't make any
sense because it wouldn't mean you would
have to arm every public place you would
have to lock every public place right
and it's really realistic to have um
armed guards everywhere all the time
wouldn't that be like a a
um welfare state
well it wouldn't be it's not a welfare
state be more like a police state police
state there you go yeah yeah yeah it's
completely unrealistic and you know the
thing about it is
they never want to just say let's try
dealing with the guns like we've talked
about all this other stuff and we've
said the issues mental illness but then
they won't fund mental health and then
they say the issues doors but then
there's an outdoor shooting and then
they say well the issue is fire escapes
but then there's one at a movie theater
you know i mean
they want to just push around the
responsibility and never deal with the
guns and you're absolutely right it's
like well i guess everybody should wear
body armor at a parade and everyone
should wear a helmet at the movies and
like how far is this going to go before
we say hey you know what let's just try
dealing with the guns
and it's like most most common sense
people are not trying to take away guns
they're just trying to make it so crazy
people don't get them yeah i mean it's
like listen there's some people who want
to get rid of the second amendment i
take a more fatalistic approach which is
like for now we have a second amendment
let's work within it let's require
liability insurance let's make
ammunition really expensive let's limit
the guns that someone under 25 can have
let's have a waiting period let's have a
psych eval let's have more extensive
training all these different things
let's just really make it so that
only the cream of the crop so to speak
can get the guns
well that's where the common sense part
comes in but we're dealing with
people without common sense and that
brings me to the next thing where yeah
i'm coming to this similar conclusion to
you where our electorate is just not
very bright right
it's like i talk to people and they talk
about gas prices inflation and they talk
about um democratic policies
and oh um the left is
too woke and the left is too this too
crazy and radical but then they very
much ignore the radicalness that's on
the right side of course
there's so much craziness that goes on
on the right um and so much
authoritarian it's all ignored because
and i like i've even heard people
that i know that are not republicans
that talk about how they like desantis
like you were saying with yeah with
i'm like really i and i don't like to
play the race car but i'm like you're a
person of color i really don't
understand he's he and or
how you um support the lgbtq community i
don't understand how you can support
anything he stands for everything he
stands for is against any of that yeah i
think he has a zero rating on lgbt stuff
i mean listen it's unfor it's really
unfortunate to mesha but we're in a
world where most people are incompetent
and i know oh it's so elitist then it's
so condescending and it's so pompous i
mean listen at this point i've worked
with a bunch of real estate agents they
were mostly all terrible at their jobs
other than two at this point i've had
you know over 20 however many years of
driving how many mechanics have i had
they've mostly been terrible at their
jobs and now i know a good mechanic uh
i've had
you know whatever like it's just it's so
common that people are just incompetent
or only minimally competent and we're
kind of trying to dance through this and
you know what
i could be incompetent too i'm not even
saying i'm exempt from this but it's a
reality that we're dealing with here
yeah i agree like i wouldn't say that i
know everything but i do try to be
informed when i form opinions i don't
just form opinions based on what
somebody tells me i try to you know do
my research and form an opinion based on
facts but it's just like some people
just listen to propaganda or news
outlets and they say well that's that's
the way things are because they said it
yes and i'm like but um there's a like
there's so much nuance even with the
vaccinations i hear people say well you
could still get it i was like there's so
much nuance that there's very variants
people didn't get it at first so it was
allowed to spread it's like there's so
much nuance to it that it's not as
simple as oh if you get if you get the
vaccine you can still get it so that
means the vaccine doesn't work it that's
just a simplified way to think of it 100
100 percent to me should the kids are
okay
yes they both a school 90 um high honors
so i'm very proud of them 90 is good
well 97 actually 97. oh my god okay
all right well great to hear from you i
appreciate it
thank you all right there's tamisha from
new york city always great to hear from
her
one of our sponsors is emmy
hands down some of the best ramen
noodles i've had just like any instant
ramen you pop emmy into the microwave or
on the stovetop for a few minutes and
it's ready to go but what makes amy
different is that it is packed with 21
grams of protein lower in sodium 100
plant-based
with 18 grams of fiber for digestive
health and it tastes
excellent
so many of the other ramens are bland
simple artificial imi uses high quality
ingredients and recipes you get a zing
of flavor i've never had with any
instant ramen emmy comes in amazing
flavors like spicy beef tom yum shrimp
and black garlic chicken if you try emmy
and don't love it
you get your money back you'll get five
dollars off when you go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman at
checkout the link is down below